hey it's Joey what could be better ideas
so a lot of people think being busy is a
good thing as if picking up pieces of
paper and putting them back down again
writing emails and you know walking
around checking your watch and basically
just having all these little minut tasks
throughout the day they think that that
is somehow synonymous with success but
there's a huge difference between being
busy and being productive and one of
those is way better than the other one
so being busy is having a lot of things
on your to-do list and being productive
is actually completing things on your
to-do list so a lot of the time people
think it's somehow honorable or
impressive to have like 25 different
things on their to-do list
even though by the end of the day they
only accomplish like three or four of
them sometimes none of them and when
people ask them to go out or do
something fun they always use that list
of responsibilities as an excuse for not
going out like all sorry I can't go to
little nephew Johnny's soccer game I've
got 25 different things I have to do I
have this email to write I've got things
to pick up from the grocery store and a
lot of the time this list of
responsibilities doesn't get any smaller
because it's so huge that people get
intimidated by the size of it paralyzing
them from doing anything that's what
it's like to be a busy person it's not
fun it's not productive it's just
stressful you know what this is so I'm
definitely guilty of this as well a lot
of the time I feel like I have so many
boxes to tick off on my to-do app that
when people come over and visit me in my
apartment I feel like I don't have I'm
not like mentally there to actually sit
down and visit with them for an extended
period of time all I'm thinking about is
all these things I have to do and it
often negatively affects my well-being
so that really got me thinking what is
the point of being busy if you're not
productive like what is the point of
having tasks to do if you're not
actually doing them and that's when I
discovered a lot of productive people
are never busy because they actually do
the things ahead of time they set aside
a time at the beginning of the day
to actually dive into deep work do the
things they need to do take care of the
responsibilities for the day so that
they free up the rest of the day to do
things like hang out with friends and
spend time with people they care about
you know being busy is completely
overrated this is really weird framing
but I want to get this guy in the shot
so here are two powerful tips to be more
busy no more productive and less busy
tip number one is to start waking up
early in the morning and use that time
as a Productivity time man I just got
way brighter in there have three or four
hours where you don't check social media
you don't do any of those menial
unimportant things like checking emails
and stuff like that and really use that
time to dive into the most important
things of the day for me that's editing
videos for my clients editing videos is
deep work it takes a lot of mental
energy and if I wait till the end of the
day I am so likely to avoid doing those
things I probably won't get them done
whereas if I do them the minute I wake
up there's a ten times greater chance
that I'll actually do them they'll be
good and I'll have the ability to focus
and put a lot of creativity into those
things my second tip is to shorten your
to-do list so take that list of 35
different things you have to do and
shorten it to three the three most
important things you have to do in a
given day and then schedule them you
know pick three things to do today
pick three things to do tomorrow and if
those are your most important six things
you have to do on those to-do lists then
congratulations you just finished the
most important things on your to-do list
what's that beeping noise I have a
really old video called how to make
better to-do lists and that's a great
place to start I'll link it in the link
in the link it in the description below
even though I hate my face in that one
and I was really bad in front of the
camera compared to how awesome I am now
shorten up your to-do lists do the
important things first thing of the day
that way you'll be clearing up time
later in the day to do the things that
you enjoy work on hobbies work on new
skills and that giant list of
responsibilities you have to do won't
become it won't be a monster in your
life anymore there are a lot of weird
noises in this house be productive
stop being busy if you like this video
hit that like button if you like videos
like these in general hit that subscribe
button also our Facebook group is
absolutely popping off so many people
are using
they're posting their self-improvement
books they're reading and all their
different things I don't know what am I
saying
if you're not part of the Facebook group
yet you're missing out big time link is
in the description below people are
posting what books they're reading what
self-improvement things they're working
on and we also have a group chat so
people are just casually talking about
you know their goals and how to
accomplish those goals also this is not
my house it's probably clear I don't
looking forward to making new content
catching the next video